The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JULIAN SHUN: Good
afternoon, everyone.
Let's get started.
So welcome to the
11th lecture of 6.172.
It seems that there
are many fewer people
here today than on Tuesday.
[LAUGHTER]
All right.
So today we're going to talk
about storage allocation.
And it turns out that
storage allocation
is about both allocating
memory and also freeing it.
But in the literature, it's
just called storage allocation,
so that's the term
we're going to use.
And whenever you do
a malloc or a free,
then you're doing
storage allocation.
So how many of you have
used malloc or free before?
So hopefully all of
you, since you needed it
for the projects and homeworks.
So the simplest form
of storage is a stack.
And in a stack, you just
have an array and a pointer.
So here we have an
array, which we call A,
and then there's some
portion of this array that's
used for memory, and the rest
of it is free-- it's not used.
And then there's a
pointer, sp, that
points to the end of the
used region in this stack.
And if you want to allocate x
bytes on the stack, all you do
is, you just increment
this sp pointer by x.
And then, of course, you
should also check for overflow
to make sure that
you don't actually
go off the end of this
array, because if you
do that then you'll get
a segmentation fault.
But actually,
nowadays, compilers
don't really check
for stack overflow
because your stack is
usually big enough for most
of your program, and when
you do get a stack overflow,
you'll just get a segfault and
then you go debug your program.
So for efficiency reasons,
the stack overflow
isn't actually checked.
OK?
And then it returns a pointer
to the beginning of the memory
that you just allocated, so
that's just as sp minus x.
So that's pretty simple.
And in fact, this is how
the C call stack works.
It also uses a stack discipline.
So when you call a function,
you save local variables
and registers on the
stack, and you also
save the return address
of the function that's
calling another function.
And then, when you return,
you pop things off the stack.
So you can also free
things from the stack.
So what you do is,
you just decrement sp
by x if you want
to free x bytes.
So here we just decremented
sp by x, and everything
after sp is now
considered to be free.
And again, if
you're careful, you
would check for a
stack underflow.
But again, the compiler
usually doesn't do this
because if you do
have a stack overflow,
there's a bug in your program,
and you'll get a segfault,
and you should go fix it.
So allocating and
freeing in a stack
takes constant time
because all you have to do
is manipulate the stack pointer,
so it's pretty efficient.
However, you have
to free consistently
with the stack discipline.
So the stack has
limited applicability.
Does anybody see why
you can't do everything
with just a stack?
So what's one
limitation of the stack?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN SHUN: So it turns
out that you can actually
pass a compile time constant
to make the stack bigger
if you wanted to.
There's actually a more
fundamental limitation
of the stack.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: You can
only read things
in the reverse order in
which you allocate them.
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah, so the
answer is that you can only
free the last thing
that you allocated,
so there's no way
to free anything
in the middle of this
used region here.
You have to free
the last thing here
because the stack doesn't
keep track of the objects
in the middle of
this used region.
So there's limited
applicability,
but it's great when it works
because it's very efficient,
and all of this code can
essentially be inline.
You don't have to have
any function calls,
so it's very fast.
And it also turns
out that you can
allocate on the call stack using
this function called alloca.
It's actually not a function.
It's just a keyword that
the compiler recognizes,
and it will transform
it to instructions
that manipulate the stack.
However, this function
is now deprecated
because it turns out that
the compiler is actually
more efficient
when you're dealing
with these fixed-size
frames if you just allocate
a pointer on the stack that
points to some piece of memory
on the heap.
But nevertheless, if you want
to allocate on the call stack,
you can call this
alloca function,
but you should check that
is doing the right thing
since it's now deprecated and
the implementation is compiler
dependent.
So what's another type of
storage besides the stack?
So you can't do
everything with a stack.
So what else can we use?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Heap.
JULIAN SHUN: Yes.
So we also have the heap, which
is more general than the stack.
So a stack looks
very nice and tidy,
and it's very efficient
to use the stack,
but it doesn't work
for everything.
So that's why we have the heap.
And a heap is much more
general, but it's very messy.
It's very hard to organize this
and work with it efficiently.
And for the rest
of this lecture,
I am going to be
talking about how
to manage memory in the heap.
And I found these pictures
on Stack Overflow,
so maybe they're
biased towards stacks.
[CHUCKLES] OK, so how do
we do heap allocation?
So let's first start with
fixed-size heap allocation,
where we assume that all of the
objects that we're dealing with
are of the same size.
In general this isn't
true, but let's just
start with this
simpler case first.
OK, so as I said earlier, if
you use malloc and free in C,
then you're doing
heap allocation.
C++ has the new and
delete operators,
which work similarly
to malloc and free.
They also call the object
constructor and destructor,
and the C functions
don't do that.
And unlike Java and Python, C
and C++ don't provide a garbage
collector, so the programmer
has to manage memory him
or herself, and this is one of
the reasons for the efficiency
of C and C++, because there's
no garbage collector running
in the background.
However, this makes
it much harder
to write correct
programs in C because you
have to be careful of memory
leaks, dangling pointers,
and double freeing.
So a memory leak is if
you allocate something
and you forget to free
it and your program keeps
running and allocating
more and more stuff
but without freeing it.
Eventually, you're going
to run out of memory,
and your program
is going to crash.
So you need to be
careful of memory leaks.
Dangling pointers are
pointers to pieces of memory
that you have already
freed, and if you
try to dereference
a dangling pointer,
the behavior is going
to be undefined.
So maybe you'll get
a segmentation fault.
Maybe you won't see anything
until later on in your program
because that memory might have
been reallocated for something
else, and it's actually legal
to dereference that memory.
So dangling pointers
are very annoying when
you're using C. If you're lucky,
you'll get a segfault right
away, and you can
go fix your bug,
but sometimes these
are very hard to find.
There's also double freeing.
So this is when you free
something more than once.
And again, this will lead
to undefined behavior.
Maybe you'll get a segfault,
or maybe that piece of memory
was allocated for
something else,
and then when you free it
again, it's actually legal.
But your program is
going to be incorrect,
so you need to be careful
that you don't free something
more than once.
And this is why
some people prefer
to use a language
like Java and Python
that provide these built-in
garbage collectors.
However, these languages
are less efficient
because they have a
general-purpose garbage
collector running
in the background.
So in this class,
we're going to use C
because we want to be able to
write the fastest programs as
possible, so we need to
study how to manage memory.
And there are some
tools you can use
to reduce the number of memory
bugs you have in your program.
So there's memory checkers like
AddressSanitizer and Valgrind,
which can assist you in
finding these pernicious bugs.
So AddressSanitizer is a
compiler instrumentation tool.
When you compile your
program, you pass a flag,
and then, when you
run your program,
it's going to report
possible memory
bugs you have in your program.
And then Valgrind-- it works
directly off the binaries.
You don't need to do anything
special when you compile it.
You can just pass your
binary to Valgrind,
and if there is a memory
bug, it might find it.
But Valgrind tends to be
slower than AddressSanitizer,
and it tends to catch
fewer bugs because it
knows less about the program
than AddressSanitizer.
And AddressSanitizer sees the
source code of the program
and has more information,
whereas Valgrind just
works directly off the binary.
Also, don't confuse the heap
with the heap data structure
that you might have seen before
in your algorithms or data
structures courses.
So these are two
different concepts.
The heap data structure
in your algorithms course
was a data structure used to
represent a priority queue,
where you can efficiently
extract the highest priority
element, and you can also
update the priorities
of elements in the set.
And this could be
used for algorithms
like sorting or graph search.
But today we're
going to be talking
about another heap,
which is the heap that's
used for storage allocation.
So don't get confused.
So any questions so far?
OK.
All right.
So we're going to first start
with fixed-size allocations,
since that's the easier case.
So we're going to assume
that every piece of storage
has the same size.
Some of these blocks are used,
and some of them are unused.
And among the
unused blocks, we're
going to keep a list that
we call the free list,
and each block in this
free list has a pointer
to the next block
in the free list.
And since this
memory is unused, we
can actually use
the memory to store
a pointer as part of our storage
allocator implementation.
There's actually another way
to do fixed-size allocations.
Instead of using
a free list, you
could actually a place a
bit for each block saying
whether or not it's free, and
then when you do allocation,
you can use bit tricks.
But today I'm going to
talk about the free list
implementation.
So to allocate one object
from the free list,
you set the pointer
x to be free.
So free is pointing to the
first object in this free list.
Then you set the
free pointer to point
to the next thing
in the free list,
so this is doing free equal
to the next pointer of free.
And then, finally,
you return x, which
is a pointer to the first
object in the free list.
So here's an animation.
So x is going to point
to what free points to.
You also need to check
if free is equal to null,
because if free
is equal to null,
that means there are no more
free blocks in the free list,
and the programmer
should know this.
You should return
a special value.
Otherwise, we're going
to set the free pointer
to point to the next
thing in the free list,
and then, finally, we
return x to the program,
and now the program has a
block of memory that I can use.
There is still a garbage
pointer in this block
that we pass back to the program
because we didn't clear it.
So the implementation
of the storage allocator
could decide to zero
this out, or it can just
pass it back to the
program and leave it up
to the programmer to do
whatever it wants with it.
So in the latter
case, the programmer
should be careful not to try
to dereference this pointer.
OK, so how about deallocation?
So let's say we want
to free some object x.
What we do is, we just
set the next pointer
of x to be equal
to free, so it's
going to point to the first
thing in the free list.
And then we set free equal to x.
So right.
So now free is pointing
to x, and this x object
that we wanted to free now is
a pointer to the first object
in the original free list.
So pretty simple.
Any questions on this?
So this sort of
acts like a stack
in that the last thing
that you've freed
is going to be the first
thing that you allocate,
so you get temporal
locality in that way.
But unlike a stack,
you can actually
free any of the blocks and
not just the last block
that you allocated.
So with a free list,
allocating and freeing
take constant time
because you're just
adjusting some pointers.
It has good temporal
locality, because as I said,
the things that you
freed most recently
are going to be the things
that are going to be allocated.
It has poor spatial locality
due to external fragmentation,
and external fragmentation means
that your box of used memory
are spread out
all over the place
in the space of all memory.
And this can be
bad for performance
because it can increase
the size of the page table,
and it can also
cause disk thrashing.
So if you recall,
whenever you access
a page in virtual memory, it
has to do address translation
to the physical memory address.
And if your memory is
spread out across many pages
in virtual memory, then you're
going to have a lot of entries
in the page table, because
the page table is storing
this mapping between the virtual
memory address of the page
and the physical memory
address of the page.
So this can complicate
the page table,
make it less efficient
to do lookups in it.
And then if you have
more pages than you
can fit in your main
memory, then this
can cause disk thrashing
because you have to move pages
in and out of disk.
The Translation Lookaside Buffer
or TLB can also be a problem.
Does anybody know what a TLB is?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: A cache of the
result of translating
from virtual memory
to physical memory.
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah, so
the TLB is essentially
a cache for the
page table, so it
will cache the results
of the translation
from virtual memory
addresses to physical memory
addresses for the most
recent translations.
And looking up a
translation in the TLB
is much more efficient than
going through the page table.
And if you have a lot of
external fragmentation,
then you have a lot of
pages that you might access,
and this means that
when you go to the TLB,
it's more likely
you'll get a TLB miss,
and you have to go
to the page table
to look up the
appropriate address.
So that's why external
fragmentation is bad.
So let's look at
some ways to mitigate
external fragmentation.
So one way to do this is to
keep a free list or a bitmap
per disk page, and then when
you want to allocate something,
you allocate from the free
list of the fullest page.
So you sort of skew
the memory that's
being used to as few
pages as possible.
And when you free
a block of storage,
you just return it to the page
on which that block resides.
And if a page becomes
completely empty--
there are no more items
that are used on that page--
then the virtual memory
system can page it out
without affecting the program
performance because you're not
going to access
that page anyways.
So this might seem
counterintuitive.
Why do we want to skew the items
to as few pages as possible?
So let's look at
a simple example
to convince ourselves why this
is actually good for dealing
with external fragmentation.
So here I have two cases.
In the first case, I have
90% of my blocks on one page
and 10% of the blocks
on the other page.
In the second case, I have
half of my blocks on one page
and half on the other page.
So now let's look
at the probability
that two random accesses
will hit the same page.
So let's assume that all
of the random accesses
are going to go to
one of the two pages.
So in the first
case, the probability
that both of the accesses
hit the first page is going
to be 0.9 times 0.9, and then
the probability that they
both hit the second
page is 0.1 times 0.1,
and if you sum this
up, you get 0.82.
That's the probability that
both of the random accesses
are going to hit the same page.
In the other case,
the probability
that both of the accesses
hit the first page
is going to be 0.5 times 0.5.
The second page is also
going to be 0.5 times 0.5,
so that sums to
0.5, and that means
that there's only a 50% chance
that two random accesses are
going to hit the same page.
So in the first
case, you actually
have a higher chance that
the two random accesses hit
the same page, and that's why we
want to skew the items as much
as possible so
that we can reduce
the external fragmentation.
Any questions?
OK, so that was fixed-size
heap allocation,
and obviously you can't
use that for many programs
if you're allocating
memory of different sizes.
So now let's look at
variable-size heap allocation.
So we're going to look at
one allocation scheme called
binned free lists.
And the idea is to leverage
the efficiency of free list
and also accept
the bounded amount
of internal fragmentation.
So internal fragmentation is
wasted space within a block,
so that means when
you allocate possibly
more space than
you're using, then
there's some wasted
space in there.
So in binned free lists,
what we're going to do is,
we're going to have a
whole bunch of bins,
and each bin is going to store
blocks of a particular size.
So here I'm going to
say that bin k holds
memory blocks of
size 2 to the k,
so I'm going to store
blocks of sizes powers of 2.
So why don't I just store a
bin for every possible size?
Does anybody know why?
Why am I rounding up
to powers of 2 here?
AUDIENCE: You'd
have too many bins.
JULIAN SHUN: Yes, if I wanted
a bin for every possible size,
I would have way too many
bins, and just the pointers
to these bins are not
going to fit in memory.
So that's why I'm only
using bins that store
blocks of size 2 to the k.
And now let's look
at how I'm going
to allocate x bytes
from a binned free list.
So what I'm going
to do is, I'm going
to look up the bin for which
I should take a block from,
and to get that, I'm going to
take the ceiling of log base x.
This is log base 2, so
recall that lg is log base 2.
If that bin is nonempty,
then I can just
return a block from that bin.
However, if that
bin is empty, then I
need to go to the next
highest bin that's nonempty,
and then I'm going to
take a block from that bin
and then split it up
into smaller chunks
and place them
into smaller bins.
And then I'll also get a chunk
that is of the right size.
So for this example, let's say
I wanted to allocate 3 bytes.
The ceiling of log base 2
of x is 2, so I go to bin 2.
But bin 2 is empty, so I need
to look for the next bin that's
not empty.
And that's going to be bin 4.
And I'm going to split up this
block into smaller powers of 2.
So in particular,
I'm going to find
a nonempty bin k
prime greater than k
and split up a block into sizes
of 2 to the k prime minus 1,
2 to the k prime minus 2, all
the way down to 2 to the k.
So I'm going to split it into
sizes of all the powers of 2
less than 2 to the k prime
and greater than or equal to 2
to the k.
And I'm going to actually have
two blocks of size 2 to the k,
and one of those will be
returned to the program.
So here I'm going to
split up this block.
I'm going to place one of the
smaller blocks in bin 3, one
of them into bin 2, and then
I also have another block here
that I'm just going to
return to the program.
So any questions on
how this scheme works?
OK, and if there are no
larger blocks that exist--
so that means all
of the bins higher
than the bin I'm
looking at are empty--
then I need to go to the OS
to request for more memory.
And then after I
get that memory,
I'll split it up so I can
satisfy my allocation request.
In practice, this exact
scheme isn't used,
so there are many
variants of this scheme.
So it turns out
that efficiency is
very important for
small allocations
because there's not
that much work performed
on these small pieces of
memory, and the overheads
of the storage allocation
scheme could cause a performance
bottleneck.
So in practice, you usually
don't go all the way down
to blocks of size 1.
You might stop at blocks
of size 8 bytes so
that you don't have
that much overhead,
but this does increase
the internal fragmentation
by a little bit, because now
you have some wasted space.
And then-- one
second-- and then you
can also group
blocks into pages,
as I said before, so that all
of the blocks in the same page
have the same size,
and then you don't
have to store the information
of the size of the blocks.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: How do you--
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah, so there
are two commands you can use.
One is called mmap and the
other one is called sbrk.
So those are system calls.
You just call that, and then the
OS will give you more memory,
and then your storage
allocator can use it.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: They don't have to
use something like this in order
to implement those?
JULIAN SHUN: No, the standard
implementation of malloc--
internally, it uses these
commands, mmap and sbrk,
to get memory from the OS,
so the OS just gives you
a huge chunk of memory.
It doesn't split it up into
smaller blocks or anything.
That's up to the
storage allocator to do.
It just gives you a
big chunk of memory,
and then the storage
allocator will break it up
into smaller blocks.
There are similar
commands where you
can free memory
back to the OS when
you're not using them anymore.
AUDIENCE: Can you explain
the paging thing [INAUDIBLE]??
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah,
so what I said
was that you can actually
keep blocks of different sizes
on different pages, so
then you don't actually
have to store the
size of each block.
You can just look up what page
that block resides in when
you get the memory address.
And then for each page,
you have one field
that stores the size of
those blocks on that page.
So this saves you the
overhead of having
to store information per
block to figure out its size.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --changing
the size of the blocks.
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah,
so I mean, if you
do change the size
of the blocks,
then you can't actually
use this scheme,
so this is actually a
variant where you don't
change the size of the blocks.
If you do change
the size, then you
have to change it
for the entire page.
Yeah, so there are many variants
of memory allocators out there.
This is just the simplest
one that I described.
But it turns out that this exact
scheme isn't the one that's
used in practice.
There are many variants.
Like some allocators,
instead of using powers of 2,
they use Fibonacci numbers to
determine the different bins.
Yeah.
Any other questions?
So you'll actually get
a chance to play around
with implementing some
allocators in project
3 and homework 6.
So let's briefly look at the
storage layout of a program.
So this is how our
virtual memory address
space is laid out.
So we have the stack
all the way at the top,
and the stack grows downwards,
so we have the high addresses
up top and the low
addresses below.
Then we have the heap,
which grows upward,
and the heap and
the stack basically
grow towards each other, and
this space is dynamically
allocated as the program runs.
Then there's the bss
segment, the data segment,
and the text segment, which
all reside below the heap.
So the code segment just stores
the code for your program.
So when you load
up your program,
this code is going to put your
program into this text segment.
Then there's this
data segment, which
stores all of the global
variables and static variables,
these constants that you
defined in your program.
These are all stored
in the data segment,
and when you load
your program you also
have to read this data
from disk and store it
into the data segment.
Then there's the bss
segment this segment is
used to store all the
on initialize variables
in your program,
and this is just
initialized to 0 at the
start of your program,
since your program
hasn't initialized it,
so it doesn't matter
what we set it to.
And then the heap--
this is the memory
that we're using when we're
calling malloc and free.
And then we have the stack,
which we talked about.
So in practice, the
stack and the heap
are never actually going to
hit each other because we're
working with 64-bit addresses.
So even though they're
growing towards each other,
you don't have to worry
about them actually
hitting each other.
And another point to
note is that if you're
doing a lot of precomputation
in your program,
for example generating these
huge tables of constants,
those all have to be
read from disk when
you start your program and
stored in this data segment.
So if you have a lot
of these constants,
it's actually going to
make your program loading
time much higher.
However, it's usually OK to do
a little bit of precomputation,
especially if you can save a
lot of computation at runtime,
but in some cases
it might actually
be faster overall to just
compute the things in memory
when you start your
program, because then you
have to read stuff from disk.
So here's a question.
So since a 64-bit address
space takes over a century
to write at a rate of 4
billion bytes per second,
we're never effectively going
to run out of virtual memory.
So why don't we just allocate
out of virtual memory and never
free anything?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: If you
allocate a bunch
of small things
in random places,
then it's harder to update
than a large segment?
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah,
so one thing is
that you have this
issue of fragmentation.
The blocks of memory
that you're using
are not going to be
contiguous in memory,
and then it makes it harder
for you to find large blocks.
So this is called
external fragmentation,
which I mentioned earlier.
So if you do this,
external fragmentation
is going to be very bad.
The performance
of the page table
is going to degrade tremendously
because the memory that you're
using is going to be spread
all over virtual memory,
and you're going
to use many pages,
and this leads to
disk thrashing.
So you have to do a lot of swaps
of pages in and out of disk.
Your TLB hit rate is
going to be very low.
And another reason
is that you're also
going to run out
of physical memory
if you never free anything.
So one of the goals
of storage allocation
is to try to use as little
virtual memory as possible
and to try to keep the
used portions of the memory
relatively compact.
Any questions so far?
OK, so let's do an analysis of
the binned free list storage
allocation scheme.
So here's a theorem.
Suppose that the maximum
amount of heap memory in use
at any time by a program is
M. If the heap is managed
by a binned free list
allocator, then the amount
of virtual memory consumed
by the heap storage
is upper bounded by
M log M. Does anybody
have an intuition about why
this theorem could be true?
So how many bins do
we have, at most?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN SHUN: Right.
So the number of bins we have
is upper bounded by log M,
and each bin is going
to use order M memory.
So let's look at
this more formally.
So an allocation request
for a block of size x
is going to consume 2 to
the ceiling of log base 2
of x storage, which is
upper bounded by 2x,
so we're only wasting a
factor of 2 storage here.
So therefore, the
amount of virtual memory
devoted to blocks of size
2 to the k is at most 2M.
And since there are at most
log base 2 of M free lists,
the theorem holds just by
multiplying the two terms.
So you can only have log
base 2 of M free lists
because that's the maximum
amount of memory you're using,
and therefore your
largest bin is only
going to hold blocks of
size M. And it turns out
that the bin free list
allocation scheme is theta
of 1 competitive with
the optimal allocator,
and here an optimal locator
knows all of the memory
requests in the future.
So it can basically do
a lot of clever things
to optimize the memory
allocation process.
But it turns out that the
binned free list is only
going to be a
constant factor worse
than the optimal allocator.
This is assuming that we don't
coalesce blocks together,
which I'll talk about
on the next slide.
It turns out that
this constant is 6,
so Charles Leiserson has a
paper describing this result.
And there's also a lower
bound of 6, so this is tight.
So coalescing.
So coalescing is when you
splice together smaller blocks
into a larger block.
So you can do this if you
have two free blocks that
are contiguous in memory.
This will allow you to put them
together into a larger block.
So binned free
lists can sometimes
be heuristically improved
by doing coalescing,
and there are many
clever schemes
for trying to find adjacent
blocks efficiently.
So there's something
called the buddy
system, where each
block has a buddy that's
contiguous and memory.
However, it turns out that this
scheme especially, the buddy
system scheme, has
pretty high overhead.
So it's usually
going to be slower
than just the standard
binned free list algorithm.
There are no good
theoretical bounds
that exist that prove the
effectiveness of coalescing,
but it does seem to work
pretty well in practice
at reducing fragmentation
because heap storage tends
to be deallocated as
a stack or in batches.
So what I mean by this is
that the objects that you free
tend to be pretty close
together in memory.
So if you deallocate as
a stack, then all of them
are going to be near
the top of the stack.
And when you
deallocate in batches--
this is when you do allocate
a whole bunch of things
that you allocated
together in your program.
For example, if you have
a graph data structure
and you allocated data for the
vertices all at the same time,
then when you deallocate
them all together,
this is going to give you a
chunk of contiguous memory
that you can splice together.
OK, so now let's look
at garbage collection.
This is going to be slightly
different from storage
allocation.
So the idea of
garbage collection
is to free the programmer
from having to free objects.
So languages like
Java and Python,
they have built-in
garbage collectors,
so the programmer doesn't
have to free stuff themselves,
and this makes it
easier to write programs
because you don't have
to worry about double
freeing and dangling
pointers and so forth.
So a garbage collector is
going to identify and recycle
the objects that the
programmer can no longer access
so that these memory objects can
be used for future allocations.
And in addition to having a
built-in garbage collector,
you can also create your
own garbage collector
in C, which doesn't have
a garbage collector.
So if you have an
application, you
can actually create a
special-purpose garbage
collector that might
be more efficient than
a general garbage collector.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: This is the previous
topic, but why [? INAUDIBLE ?]
order of M memory?
JULIAN SHUN: Why
is it not order M?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JULIAN SHUN: Because
for each of the bins,
you could use up
to order M memory.
So if you don't do
coalescing, basically, I
could have a bunch
of small allocations,
and then I chop up
all of my blocks,
and then they all go
into smaller bins.
And then I want to
allocate something larger.
I can't just splice
those together.
I have to make another
memory allocation.
So if you order your memory
requests in a certain way,
you can make it so that each
of the bins has order M memory.
OK, so for garbage collection,
let's go over some terminology.
So there are three types
of memory objects, roots,
live objects, and dead objects.
Roots are objects
that are directly
accessible by the program, so
these are global variables,
things on the stack, and so on.
Then there are
live objects, which
are reachable by following
the roots via pointers,
and then finally,
there are dead objects,
and these objects are
inaccessible via sequences
of pointers.
And these can be recycled
because the programmer can
no longer reach
these dead objects.
So in order for garbage
collection to work in general,
you need to be able to have
the garbage collector identify
pointers, and this
requires strong typing.
So languages like Python
and Java have strong typing,
but in C, it doesn't
have strong typing.
This means that when
you have a pointer
you don't actually know
whether it's a pointer.
Because a pointer just
looks like an integer.
It could be either a
point or an integer.
You can cast things
in C. You can also
do pointer arithmetic
in C. So in contrast,
in other languages, once
you declare something
to be a pointer, it's always
going to be a pointer.
And for those languages
that have strong typing,
this makes it much easier
to do garbage collection.
You also need to prohibit
doing pointer arithmetic
on these pointers.
Because if you do
pointer arithmetic
and you change the
location of the pointer,
then the garbage
collector no longer
knows where the memory
region starts anymore.
In C, sometimes you do
do pointer arithmetic,
and that's why
you can't actually
have a general-purpose garbage
collector in C that works well.
So let's look at one simple
form of garbage collection.
And this is called
reference counting.
The idea is that,
for each object,
I'm going to keep a count of the
number of pointers referencing
that object.
And if the count ever
goes to 0, then that
means I can free that
object because there
are no more pointers that
can reach that object.
So here, I have
a bunch of roots.
So these are directly
accessible by my program.
And then I have a
bunch of objects
that can be reached
via following pointers
starting from the root.
And then each of them
have a reference count
that indicates how many
incoming pointers they have.
So let's say now I change
one of these pointers.
So initially, I had a
pointer going to here,
but now I changed it so
that it goes down here.
So what happens now is I have
to adjust a reference counts
of both of these objects.
So this object
here, now it doesn't
have any incoming pointers, so I
have to decrement its reference
count.
So that goes to 0.
And then for this one, I have to
increment its reference count,
so now it's 3.
And now I have an object that
has a reference count of 0,
and with this reference
counting algorithm,
I can free this object.
So let's go ahead
and free this object.
But when I free this
object, it actually
has pointers to other
objects, so I also
have to decrement the reference
counts of these other objects
when I free this object.
So I'm going to
decrement the counts.
And now it turns out
that this object also
has a reference count of 0,
so I can free that, as well.
And in general, I just
keep doing this process
until the reference
counts of the objects
don't change anymore, and
whenever I encounter an object
with a reference count of 0,
I can free it immediately.
And the memory that I
freed can be recycled.
It can be used for future
memory allocations.
So questions on how
the reference counting
procedure works?
So there's one issue
with reference counting.
Does anybody see
what the issue is?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What if it has
a reference to itself?
JULIAN SHUN: Yes.
So what if it has a
reference to itself?
More generally, what
if it has a cycle?
You can't ever collect
garbage collect a cycle when
you're using reference counts.
So here we have a
cycle of length 3.
They all have a
reference count of 1,
but you can never reach the
cycle by following pointers
from the root,
and therefore, you
can never delete any
object in the cycle,
and the reference counts are
always going to be non-zero.
So let's just
illustrate the cycle.
And furthermore, any object
that's pointed to by objects
in the cycle cannot be
garbage collected, as well,
because you can't garbage
collect the cycle,
so all the pointer is going out
of the objects in the cycle are
always going to be there.
So there could be a lot
of objects downstream
from this object here that
can't be garbage collected,
so this makes it very bad.
And as we all know,
uncollected garbage stinks,
so we don't want that.
So let's see if we can come up
with another garbage collection
scheme.
So it turns out that
reference counting is actually
pretty good when it
does work because it's
very efficient and
simple to implement.
So if you know that
your program doesn't
have these cycles in
them among pointers,
then you can use a
reference counting scheme.
There are some languages,
like Objective-C,
that have two different types
of pointers, strong pointers
and weak pointers.
And if you're doing
reference counting
with a language with these
two types of pointers,
the reference count
only stores the number
of incoming strong pointers.
And therefore, if you define
these pointers inside a cycle
to be weak pointers,
they're not going
to contribute to
the reference count,
and therefore you can
still garbage collect.
However, programming with
strong or weak pointers
can be kind of
tricky because you
need to make sure that you're
not dereferencing something
that a weak pointer points
to because that thing might
have been garbage
collected already,
so you need to be careful.
And C doesn't have these
two types of pointers,
so we need to use another
method of garbage collection
to make sure we can garbage
collect these cycles.
So we're going to look at
two more garbage collection
schemes.
The first one is
called mark-and-sweep,
and the second one is
called stop-and-copy.
So first we need to define
a graph abstraction.
So let's say we have a graph
with vertices V and edges E.
And the vertex at V
contains all of the memory
objects in memory,
and the edges E are
directed edges between objects.
So there's a directed
edge from object A
to object B if object A
has a pointer to object B.
And then, as we said earlier,
the live objects are the ones
that are reachable
from the roots,
so we can use a
breadth-first-search-like
procedure to find all
of the live objects.
So we just start our
breadth-first search
from the roots,
and we'll mark all
of the objects that can be
reachable from the roots.
And then everything
else that isn't reached,
those are available
to be reclaimed.
So we're going to
have a FIFO queue,
First-In, First-Out queue,
for our breadth-first search.
This is represented as an array.
And we have two pointers,
one to the head of the queue
and one to the
tail of the queue.
And here let's look at this
code, which essentially
is like a breadth-first search.
So we're first going to go over
all the vertices in our graph,
and we're going to check
if each vertex v is a root.
If it is a root, we're going
to set its mark to be 1,
and we're going to place
the vertex onto the queue.
And otherwise, we're going
to set the mark of v to be 0.
And then while the
queue is not empty,
we're going to dequeue the
first thing from the queue.
Let that be u.
Then we're going to look at all
the outgoing neighbors of u.
So these are vertices
v such that there
is a directed edge from u
to v. We're going to check
if v's mark is equal to 0.
If it is, that means we
haven't explored it yet,
so we'll set its mark to be 1,
and we place it onto the queue.
And if the neighbor has
already been explored,
then we don't have
to do anything.
So let's illustrate how
this algorithm works
on this simple graph here.
And for this example,
I'm just going
to assume that I have
one root, vertex r.
In general, I can
have multiple routes,
and I just place all
of them onto the queue
at the beginning,
but for this example,
I'm just going to
have a single root.
So I'm going to place it onto
the queue, and the location
that I place it is going to be
where the tail pointer points
to.
And after I placed
it on the queue,
I increment the tail pointer.
Now I'm going to take
the first thing off
of my queue, which is r, and
I'll explore my neighbors.
So the neighbors
are b and c here.
Both of them haven't been marked
yet, so I'm going to mark them,
and I'm going to indicate
the marked vertices
with shaded blue.
And I'll place them
onto the queue.
Now I'm going to take
the next thing, b.
I'm going to check
its neighbors.
It only has a neighbor to c,
but c is already on the queue.
It's already marked, so I
don't have to do anything.
Now I dequeue c, and c
has neighbors d and e,
so I place them onto the queue.
d doesn't have any
outgoing neighbors,
so I don't to do anything.
Now when I dequeue e,
it has neighbors f.
When I dequeue f,
it has a neighbor g,
and when I dequeue g, it
doesn't have any neighbors.
So now my queue is empty, and my
breadth-first search procedure
finishes.
So at this point,
I've marked all
of the objects that are
accessible from the root,
and all of the unmarked
objects can now
be garbage collected
because there is no way I
can access them in the program.
So the mark-and-sweep
procedure has two stages.
The first stage is
called the mark stage,
where I use a
breadth-first search
to mark all of the live objects.
And the sweep stage
will scan over memory
to free the unmarked objects.
So this a pretty simple scheme.
There is one issue
with this scheme.
Does anybody see what
the possible issue is?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: You have to scan
over all the [INAUDIBLE]..
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah, so that's
one issue, where you have
to scan over all of memory.
There are some variants
of mark-and-sweep
where it keeps track of
just the allocated objects,
so you only have to
scan over those instead
of the entire memory space.
Besides that, are there
any other possible issues
with this?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: This also requires
that you [INAUDIBLE]
strong typing.
JULIAN SHUN: Right,
so let's assume
that we do have strong typing.
Any other possible limitations?
Anybody else?
Think I called on--
yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
reference counting,
you can see the object
that has a reference to it,
whereas for here you can find
everything that would not be
garbage collected [INAUDIBLE].
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah, so for
the scheme that I described,
you have to look over
all of the things that
don't have references to it.
So that is another overhead.
So those are all issues.
Good.
The issue I want
to get at is that
the mark-and-sweep algorithm
that I presented here
doesn't deal with fragmentation.
So it doesn't compact
the live objects
to be contiguous in memory.
It just frees the ones
that are unreachable,
but it doesn't do anything with
the ones that are reachable.
So let's look at
another procedure that
does deal with fragmentation.
This is called the stop-and-copy
garbage collection procedure.
At a high level, it's
pretty similar to
the mark-and-sweep algorithm.
We're still going to use
a breadth-first search
to identify all of
the live objects.
But if you look at how this
breadth-first search is
implemented, is
there any information
you can use here to try to
get the live objects to be
contiguous in memory?
Does anybody see anything
here that we can use
to try to reduce fragmentation?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN SHUN: Yes,
so the answer is
that the objects that we visited
are contiguous on the queue.
So in the mark-and-sweep
algorithm,
I just place the IDs of
the vertices on the queue,
but if I just place the actual
objects onto the queue instead,
then I can just use my
queue as my new memory.
And then all of the objects
that are unreachable
will be implicitly deleted.
So this procedure here will deal
with external fragmentation.
So let's see how this works.
So we're going to have
two separate memory
spaces, the FROM space
and the TO space.
So in the FROM space, I'm
just going to do allocation
and freeing on it
until it becomes full.
So when I allocate
something I place it
at the end of this space.
When I free something,
I just market as free,
but I don't compact it out yet.
And when this FROM
space becomes full,
then I'm going to run my
garbage collection algorithm,
and I'm going to use
the TO space as my queue
when I do my
breadth-first search.
So after I run my breadth-first
search, all of the live objects
are going to appear in the
TO space in contiguous memory
since I used the TO
space as my queue.
Right, and then I just
keep allocating stuff
from the TO space and
also marking things
as deleted when I free
them until the TO space
becomes full.
Then I do the same thing,
but I swap the roles
of the TO and the FROM spaces.
So this is called the
stop-and-copy algorithm.
There is one problem
with this algorithm
which we haven't addressed yet.
Does anybody see what
the potential problem is?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: If nothing
is dead, then you're
copying over your entire
storage every single time.
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah, so
that's one good observation.
If nothing is dead, then
you're wasting a lot of work
because you have to copy this.
Although with the
mark-and-sweep algorithm,
you still have to
do some copying,
although you're not
copying the entire objects.
You're just copying the IDs.
There's actually a
correctness issue here.
So does anybody see what
the correct this issue is?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So maybe the
pointers in the TO space
have to be changed in order to
point to the new [INAUDIBLE]..
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah,
so the answer is
that if you had pointers that
pointed to objects in the FROM
space, if you move your
objects to the TO space,
those pointers aren't going
to be correct anymore.
So if I had a pointer
to a live object before
and I moved my live object to
a different memory address,
I need to also
update that pointer.
So let's see how we
can deal with this.
So the idea is that,
when an object is copied
to the TO space, we're
going to store a forwarding
pointer in the
corresponding object
in the from space, and
this implicitly marks
that object as moved.
And then when I remove
an object from the FIFO
queue in my breadth-first
search, in the TO space
I'm going to update
all of the pointers
by following these
forwarding pointers.
So let's look at an
example of how this works.
So let's say I'm executing
the breadth-first search,
and this is my current
queue right now.
What I'm going to do is,
when I dequeue an element
from my queue, first I'm
going to place the neighboring
objects that haven't been
explored yet onto the queue.
So here it actually
has two neighbors,
but the first one has already
been placed the queue,
so I can ignore it.
And the second one hasn't
been placed on the queue yet,
so I place it onto the queue.
And then I'm also going to--
oh, so this object
also has a pointer
to something in the FROM
space, which I'm not
going to change at this time.
But I am going to store
a forwarding pointer
from the object that I
moved from the FROM space
to the TO space, so
now it has a pointer
that tells me the new address.
And then, for the object
that I just dequeued,
I'm going to follow
the forwarding
pointers of its neighbors,
and that will give me
the correct addresses now.
So I'm going to update the
pointers by just following
the forwarding pointer.
So the first pointer
pointed to this object,
which has a forwarding pointer
to this, so I just make a point
to this object in the TO space.
And then similarly
for the other pointer,
I'm going to make it
point to this object.
So that's the
that's the idea how
of how to adjust the pointers.
One question is, why can't
we just adjust the pointer
is when we enqueue the object?
So why do I have to
adjust the pointers
when I dequeue an object?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Because we haven't
processed its neighbors yet.
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah,
so the answer is
that, when you enqueue
object, you don't actually
know where your
neighbors are going
to reside in the TO space.
And you only know that when
you dequeue the object,
because when you
dequeue the object,
you must have explored
your neighbors,
and therefore you can generate
these forward pointers.
So any questions on this scheme?
So how much time does it take to
do the stop-and-copy procedure?
So let's say n is
the number of objects
and the number of
pointers I have,
so it's the sum of the number of
objects and number of pointers.
How much time would it
take to run this algorithm?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah,
so it's just going
to be linear time because we're
running a breadth-first search,
and that takes linear time.
You also have to
do work in order
to copy these objects
to the TO space,
so you also have to
do work proportional
to the number of bytes
that you're copying over.
So it's linear in the
number of objects,
the number of pointers, and
the total amount of space
or copying over.
And the advantage
of this scheme is
that you don't actually need
to go over the objects that
aren't reachable because those
are going to be implicitly
deleted because they're not
copied over to the TO space,
whereas in the
mark-and-sweep procedure,
you had to actually go
through your entire memory
and then free all the objects
that aren't reachable.
So this makes the stop-and-copy
procedure more efficient,
and it also deals with the
external fragmentation issue.
So what happens when the
FROM space becomes full?
So what you do is, you're
going to request a new heap
space equal to the used
space, so you're just
going to double the
size of your FROM space.
And then you're going to
consider the FROM space to be
full when the newly
allocated space becomes full,
so essentially what
you're going to do
is, you're going to
double the space,
and when that becomes
full, you're going
to double it again, and so on.
And with this method,
you can amortize
the cost of garbage collection
to the size of the new heap
space, so it's going to be
amortized constant overhead
per byte of memory.
And this is assuming
that the user
program is going to touch all
of the memory that it allocates.
And furthermore, the
virtual memory space
required by this scheme
is just a constant times
the optimal if you locate
the FROM and the TO spaces
in different regions
of virtual memory
so that they can't
interfere with each other.
And the reason why it's a
constant times the optimal
is because you only
lose a factor of 2
because you're maintaining
two separate spaces.
And then another factor
of 2 comes from the fact
that you're doubling the size of
your array when it becomes full
and up to half of
it will be unused.
But it's constant times
optimal since we're just
multiplying constants together.
And similarly, when
you're FROM space
becomes relatively empty--
for example, if it's
less than half full--
you can also release
memory back to the OS,
and then the analysis of the
amortized constant overhead
is similar.
OK, any other questions?
OK, so there's a lot more
that's known and also unknown
about dynamic
storage allocation,
so I've only scratched the
surface of dynamic storage
allocation today.
There are many other topics.
For example, there's the buddy
system for doing coalescing.
There are many variants of
the mark-and-sweep procedure.
So there are optimizations to
improve the performance of it.
There's generational
garbage collection,
and this is based on the
idea that many objects are
short-lived, so a
lot of the objects
are going to be freed
pretty close to the time
when you allocate it.
And for the ones that
aren't going to be freed,
they tend to be
pretty long-lived.
And the idea of generational
garbage collection
is, instead of scanning your
whole memory every time,
you just do work on the younger
objects most of the time.
And then once in
a while, you try
to collect the garbage
from the older objects
because those tend to
not change that often.
There's also real-time
garbage collection.
So the methods I
talked about today
assume that the program isn't
running when the garbage
collection procedure is
running, but in practice, you
might want to actually have
your garbage collector running
in the background when
your program is running,
but this can lead to
correctness issues
because the static
algorithms I just described
assume that the graph of
the objects and pointers
isn't changing, and when
the objects and pointers are
changing, you need to
make sure that you still
get a correct answer.
Real-time garbage collection
tends to be conservative,
so it doesn't always free
everything that's garbage.
But for the things that
it does decide to free,
those can be actually reclaimed.
And there are various techniques
to make real-time garbage
collection efficient.
One possible way is, instead
of just having one FROM
and TO space, you can have
multiple FROM and TO spaces,
and then you just work on
one of the spaces at a time
so that it doesn't
actually take that long
to do garbage collection.
You can do it incrementally
throughout your program.
There's also multithreaded
storage allocation
and parallel garbage collection.
So this is when you have
multiple threads running,
how do you allocate memory, and
also how do you collect garbage
in the background.
So the algorithms become
much trickier because there
are multiple threads
running, and you
have to deal with races
and correctness issues
and so forth.
And that's actually a
topic of the next lecture.
So in summary,
these are the things
that we talked about today.
So we have the most basic form
of storage, which is a stack.
The limitation of a stack is
that you can only free things
at the top of the stack.
You can't free arbitrary
things in the stack,
but it's very efficient when
it works because the code is
very simple.
And it can be inlined,
and in fact this
is what the C calling
procedure uses.
It places local variables
in the return address
of the function on the stack.
The heap is the more
general form of storage,
but it's much more
complicated to manage.
And we talked about various
ways to do allocation
and deallocation for the heap.
We have fixed-size
allocation using
free lists, variable-size
binned free lists, and then
many variants of these ideas
are used in practice.
For garbage collection,
this is where
you want to free the programmer
from having to free objects.
And garbage
collection algorithms
are supported in languages
like Java and Python.
We talked about various ways
to do this reference counting,
which suffers from
the limitation
that it can't free cycles.
Mark-and-sweep and
stop-and-copy-- these
can free cycles.
The mark-and-sweep
procedure doesn't
deal with external
fragmentation,
but the stop-and-copy
procedure does.
We also talked about internal
and external fragmentation.
So external fragmentation is
when your memory blocks are all
over the place in
virtual memory.
This can cause performance
issues like disk thrashing
and TLB misses.
Then there's internal
fragmentation,
where you're actually
not using all
of the space in the
block that you allocate.
So for example, in the
binned free list algorithm,
you do have a little bit
of internal fragmentation
because you're always rounding
up to the nearest power of 2
greater than the size you
want, so you're wasting up
to a factor of 2 in space.
And in project 3,
you're going to look
much more at these storage
allocation schemes,
and then you'll also get to try
some of these in homework 6.
So any other questions?
So that's all I have
for today's lecture.